[Music]
the union representing metro officers is
calling for a judge to resign after
comments she made about police while she
was still on the bench this is clark
county district court judge erica baloo
you're a black man in america you know
you don't want to be nowhere where cops
are listen i listen to you you listen to
me you know you don't want to be nowhere
where cops are because i know i don't
and i'm a middle-aged middle-class black
woman i don't want to be around where
the cops are because i don't know if i'm
going to walk away alive or not
so those comments coming during a
hearing with the da's office which
wanted to revoke the probation of the
man judge balu was addressing now while
on probation that man is accused of
committing battery against an officer
the las vegas police protective
association sending the eight news now
i-team a statement which reads in part
here we call upon judge ballou to resign
from the bench we also asked the
judicial ethics commission to sanction
her for violating the nevada code of
judicial conduct
the union insisting judge baloo's
comment showed that she is biased
against law enforcement judge erica blew
responding saying quote i support proper
law enforcement what the record shows is
that i communicate with those who appear
before me in a manner that is
straightforward and understandable